[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 es la cita
ineludible para los cineastas árabes y
africanos la edición número 33 de las
jordanas cinematográficas de Cartago
abrió sus puertas en túnez hasta el 5 de
noviembre se proyectarán 170 películas
en 22 salas de la capital y otras
ciudades y 12 largometrajes participan
en la competencia oficial la lista
incluye la película su lesilla bajo los
higos que trata sobre las relaciones
amorosas durante el periodo de cosecha
causó una gran impresión en los
principales festivales internacionales
de Khan Venecia Londres y Toronto y
representará a túnez en la carrera por
los Oscar 2023 en las jornadas
cinematográficas de Cartago fue su
primera proyección en túnez su directora
la francontunecina
nos cuenta más es una película sobre la
juventud la juventud de las regiones la
juventud del campo la juventud con
acentos que rara vez se escuchan en el
cine y ya es hora de que esos acentos se
escuchen en el cine también es una
película sobre mujeres que se hacen
valer y sobre hombres jóvenes que
cuentan sus propias historias y también
sus frustraciones a veces
[Música]
lugar
en las otras noticias culturales de la
semana la escritora ganó el galardón más
prestigioso de las letras francesas el
premio
llegó de 62 años es la décimo tercera
mujer en obtener esta recompensa con su
dibujo
vivir de prisa una obra que busca
descifrar los misterios del accidente
mortal de moto que sufrió su esposo en
1999 y que los críticos aclamaron por
ser conmovedora pero sin caer en golpes
bajos veamos la reacción de la escritora
después del anunció de su Victoria
quiero agradecerles a los miembros de la
academia gong por leer un libro que la
prensa ha dicho muchas veces que era
íntimo
Don la casa encima
y me parece como acabo de decir que la
intimidad solo tiene sentidos y resuena
en lo colectivo con una sociedad con una
época con una historia
quiero pensar imagino que ellos también
vieron esta dimensión que es mucho más
una simple vida íntima y que un simple
destino que si se le priva de otros no
tiene mucho sentido
en Chile la Comic con festejo sus 10
años y para celebrar la ocasión las
primeras mil entradas se vendieron al
costo simbólico de 10 besos chilenos es
decir un céntimo de dólar después de dos
años de ausencia por la pandemia de Kobe
19 los aficionados acudieron en masa a
esta convención que celebra la cultura
pop y donde se mezclan los mundos del
cine la televisión los videojuegos los
cómics y la Ilustración
[Aplausos]
otras puertas se reabrieron al público
en Estados Unidos las de la corona de la
Estatua de la Libertad los turistas
pueden de nuevo acceder a uno de los
miradores más emblemáticos del país un
lugar donde caben solo 12 personas a la
vez después de subir 162 escalones Lo
que equivale a una altura de 10 pisos
nos quedamos en Estados Unidos y abrimos
nuestra sección dedicada a la música con
la muerte del rapero estadounidense
tacos en la noche del 31 de octubre al
primero de noviembre el miembro del
exitoso Trío Unidos Fue asesinado a
tiros en una fiesta privada en una
bolera del centro de Houston en el
estado de Texas originario de la ciudad
de Atlanta ateicos tenía 28 años nos
fanáticos al igual que la crítica
saludaron a un artista importante de la
escena hip hop
guabo incluso dijo que Jacob fue
probablemente el mejor de Los tres
cuabo era el tío de Take off
en juego eran primos se crearon juntos
Así que es una situación desafortunada
para la comunidad del hip hop una vez
más bien
que ya ha perdido a numerosos factores
de primera línea desde los menos
conocidos hasta los demás altos perfil
nos quedamos en Estados Unidos para
hablar de la nueva canción de la
cantante y actriz la estrella emergente
del ahora dice unió a la rapera lato
para el tema for the Nights
[Música]
y del lado de España al grupo madrileño
taburete colaboró con Omar Montes y la
húngara para crear la canción camarón
una fusión de pop rock y flamenco que
rinde homenaje al famoso cantante de
Cádiz camarón de La Isla
Nos despedimos con el reggae en vivo de
los brasileños naziruts que invitaron a
Isa en el tema Goodbye Direction Gracias
a ustedes por su confianza y sigan con
nosotros hay más cultura en francés
24.com
[Música]